[Music]
hello and welcome to this video this is
the first video about the new zou Indian
and it deals with the sidelines
beginning that white may play the most
important one among those is the
Leningrad with Bishop g5 but there are
also some other moves to consider so
let's have a look so we have deform none
of 6046 and now Knight f3 d5 Knight c3
Bishop before is the rogozin but Knight
c3 is of course also very frequently
seen move which after Bishop b4 leads us
to the nimzo-indian the second
cornerstone of this repertoire the names
o is a very popular opening on all
levels in particular on the lower levels
actually on the non pro
you see Knights here three more often
than Knight f3 the professional players
often a knight of 3 or g3 because they a
little bit more afraid of the numa so
afraid is a strong word but the names o
has a very very good theoretical
standing and this often avoided by white
players so what is the good thing about
the Newman's Own I think and always felt
this way the names o is a very flexible
opening with Bishop B form we pin the
knight and their form get a little bit
of central influence like a form we
prevent it now by technical means so we
increased control over the center with
this move without committing to a
central structure yet it's not clear at
all whether we want to play d5 or c5 or
b6 or yeah a combination of any of those
moves and this makes it a very
interesting opening and also an opening
that once you have it in your repertoire
can be modified to no end basically you
can still play your opening but you can
always add a little bit of variety like
girl why not this line or why not try
something else
so while still
staying within your arm kind of knowing
territory you can still vary a little
bit which makes it I think a very good
long-term addition to any opening
repertoire okay now we look at the
sidelines here in the Sun chapter as
mentioned the most important one among
those is Bishop to g5 um but let's have
a look at some others and they actually
will transpose quite often let's say
Knight f3 this is a very easy one for
our repertoire as we simply play d5 and
we transpose to the Rogozin so we
basically young save a good amount of
theoretical effort here this is a not
the only move of course when I wrote my
book on the new mezzo in 2015 2014
I recommended c5 as an entirely
different way to play but you can also
Castle you can play B 6 so with d5 you
have already made answer with this
repertoire but it is extremely flexible
for later modification um another move
that is seen quite often on the non-pro
is Bishop this was a free preview of our
entire one d4 course based on the
Dominion and rogozin available on chess
about calm thanks for watching and see
you soon
[Music]